[Music]
i'm so sorry i forgot to tell you but
you're not feeling very well and the
only way to cure it is if we stay home
all day and i tend to you and kiss you
and cook
bye
[Music]
is safe and secure
here you can live the life you deserve
frank has built something truly special
what he's created out here it's it's a
different way
a better way
victory has things money can't buy
i lived next door you wouldn't believe
the things i've heard
jack and alice only had time for each
other
what is the
enemy of progress chaos yes
nasty word
chaos
the one thing they ask of us is to stay
here
where it's safe
i was here when you got here
yeah you sleep in the bedroom
[Music]
that's good just breathe
most of my patients have had nightmares
i have some pills i can prescribe for
that
violet where did you meet phil we met on
a train to boston you dropped your
ticket and he bent down picked it up
gave it to you right
not everyone gets this opportunity
what are we doing changing the world
what are we doing changing the world
we're lying about everything
keep calm and carry on
i gave you all of this alice it's all
about control
i know exactly who you are
[Music]
i've been waiting for someone like you
someone
to challenge me
like a good girl
[Music]
you